so what exactly is synthetic
substitution and how do we utilize it
well you know previously how to work
with direct substitution you say well hm
if I want to evaluate F of two whatever
is in the parenthesis here we replace
that X on the right with two and we
simplify so let's just do that just to
kind of Refresh on the direct
substitution method and then I'll show
you the synthetic substitution method
which is also referred to as the
remainder theorem and I'll show you why
that is as well so remember when you do
this you want to do the order of
operations parentheses then exponents
then multiplication the pemos right so 2
cubed is 8 * 2 is 16 2^ 2 is 4 * 3 is 12
4 * 2 is 8 + 1 so if we add these
together we get 4 + 8 is 12 + 1 is 13 so
you can see that F of 2 is equal to 13
that's the old way the direct
substitution way now what I want to show
you is the synthetic substitution method
and what you're going to do is you're
going to take the coefficients in front
of our variables here just like as if
you were doing synthetic division
remember if you go from X Cub to X you
want to put a placeholder like a zero or
if you're missing a constant it would be
zero so you want to make sure it goes in
descending order then what you do is you
drop down that first number you multiply
on the diagonal so 2 * 2 is four and
then you add straight down multiplying
the
diagonal add straight down multiplying
and the
diagonal add straight down and this last
number if you remember from synthetic
division this is our remainder but the
remainder you can see is the exact same
thing that we got when we did the direct
substitution so our remainder is
actually our answer so we're putting two
into our function we're getting 13 out
on a graph if you were graphing this
polinomial when x equals 2 y would be up
here at 13 now sometimes students get a
little bit confused because they say
Mario when I was doing synthetic
division I always change this number to
the opposite so like if you were
dividing by x + 2 you would put -2 here
or if you were dividing by xus 2 you'd
put positive2 here you don't do that
when you're doing the synthetic
substitution method if you're evaluating
F of two you just put two and it's the
exact same let's look at another example
see if you can try this one on your own
so we've got f ofx = x 4 - 2x^2 + 7 and
we want to evaluate what is f of -3 so
what do you think how would you do that
one now I would use a synthetic method
but then also do the direct method to
check your work and get some practice
with this one and while you do that I
just want to let you know about my
courses real quick I've got an algebra 1
and algebra 2C col algebra video course
for sale I've got links in the
description check those out if you're
taking those courses or want to dive
deeper with me into those two courses so
let's go uh to this problem now how
would we actually evaluate this well
using the synthetic method we're going
to start off with our coefficients we've
got 1 x to 4th 0x Cub so we're going to
put that
placeholder -2X 2 0x another placeholder
and then seven so we had two missing
terms here we drop down that first
number we multiply in the diagonal we
add straight down we multiply in the
diagonal we add straight down we
multiply in the
multiply in the diagonal and we add
straight down and this last number this
is like our remainder when we were doing
synthetic division remember so they call
it the remainder theorem but this is
actually our answer f of-3 is equal to
70 now let's check our work by putting
-3 in directly so we've got 1 * -3 4 - 2
* -3 2 + 7 -3 4 is3 * -3 * 3 * -3 which
is
81 and -32 is 9 * -2 is going to be a 8
or -8
+ 7 so let's see what do we get here
we've got um 88 - 18 which is 70 and
that's the same thing we got right here
so sometimes when you're doing these
problems the synthetic substitution
method can be a little bit quicker and
so that's why it's a handy technique to
use if you want to see more examples
follow me over to that video that I did
right there talking more about this
technique so you can get some more
practice and do some more problems on
your own I'll see you over in that video
video